governor steve siselek says nevada will  receive the first vaccine doses by  mid-december here in just a few weeks  and frontline workers and those most at  risk will be among the first to receive  it  nevada will get that vaccine produced by  pfizer and moderna  currently they are 95 effective we're  told both will have to be administered  in two separate doses  either three or four weeks apart  we're closer to the end than we are to  the beginning and there is definitely a  light at the end of the tunnel  there's no doubt that this vaccine these  vaccines will play a pivotal role  in helping combat this disease but it  will take time to make sure everyone  has access to the vaccine the governor  says until that happens we must continue  to avoid large gatherings stay home as  much as possible  and keep wearing a mask